i think our second day they're like
they're like just walk down the hall and
do whatever you want and you'll make
everything better and you're like that's
that's crazy talk these are these smart
people here
oh but i mean they kind of mean it
um and so like the very first thing i
did at valve was i complained i really
liked the game david defeat source we
were play testing internally i'm like
the website sucks
and
greg coomer's just like well why don't
you just go do the website then
and so with q the graphic designer we
just redid the website
um
so what was that
yeah during the orange box um
the playstation was being done kind of
out of house the um
xbox was being done in-house and i was
the first person who was like playing
the full
if you remember it also had like half
life in it and half half life two in it
and everything else so the first person
playing through that on the xbox and
playing like uh
a bunch of that stuff
uh and i realized that we just were not
gonna hit q a like we had no idea what
certification was and like oh my god
were we failing and like like every like
i was playing at the qa manual like a
certification manual like we are failing
everything
so i went with john morello one of the
animators and we're both like we've got
to fix this and so we just took over qa
and essentially um grabbed everybody's
dev kit out of their offices put them in
the hallway
and started running this qa process
because morello was super
i am not detail-oriented i i can try all
my life i never will be he was and so
together we just kind of created this
kind of testing plan i mean that's not
right like
that's to me that's the fun thing at
valve you see a problem you act like
it's your company and how do you solve
this well i'm just going to go do this
and
even like the flat hierarchy worked
really well on like episode one where
the flat hierarchy didn't work well when
we had three teams doing different
things right like you started needing to
have leads be a little bit more
prominent
excuse me um so like that's always been
there and for for but the underlying
idea is
that the person who is best to solve the
problem who understands it the best and
working on it is the one doing the work
and deciding the work
versus having like a designer sitting on
top just generating a bunch of paper
designs and making engineers go off and
do it
it's more of a collaborative process
with that and i always think if
somebody's really passionate and excited
you don't know how that expresses itself
and it doesn't always express itself in
their craft exactly and sometimes that
just may be an idea maybe a really good
idea and you just want to capture that
idea and make sure it's there right
and so it's like when we were writing
even for the portal series it'd always
be like hey we're going to go off and
record a bunch of stuff does anybody
have things we should be putting in here
like does anyone have ideas like
always take those ideas and steal them
and make them your own um but like right
but like you should always be
collaborative that way and i think
that's the strength of
like kind of that valve process i think
people get caught up in the flat and
the handbook and
like there's a lot of
garbage around it that isn't helpful but
that idea of just the people doing the
work are kind of in charge of the work
and are able to make their own decisions
is an important part of it and that's
that's what scales and inside of the
teams that scales and that works and
that's what we try to do as well
and it's not that um there are no
managers
it's that everybody's your manager
and so we're going to go ship left 4
dead 1 and an engineer comes up to me is
like i think we really should package
these as groups of four we should never
sell the game solo it's only fun with
your friends
um that's the only way this game's ever
gonna be successful
okay he has a valid argument that he's
making
he's
making it from a point of a bunch of
information he has talking about other
examples and everything else and then i
have to be able to respond i can't just
be like well off you know right
like excuse me
no you can say that it's fine
right like you can't just say that you
have to be like okay you have to take
that in and go okay
and so then with that is
everybody can give you information
everyone give you feedback everyone give
you information but that does not mean
you need to act on it what you need to
do is go okay why are they saying this
what is their worry what is their
concern or is there a valid point here
or are they right because valve
doesn't really have a process per se
like the process is sort of whatever you
make it
so i wasn't coming in going oh okay
these are all the tried and true methods
i used to make this work it was sort of
like this is a different project than
we've ever done with a different team
than we've ever done with different
people so how are you going to make it
work make it work you know and i'm like
you know however old i was at time like
26 i'm like great thanks so a lot of it
was just trying to do it on the fly and
you know
trying to find like management software
that was all useless and yeah in the end
it was just all
google documents you know but when you
have a boss you have somebody to
complain about or somebody to blame you
know to blame right and when there's
nobody above you it really is a
a different sense you kind of have to
it's a real adjustment because you
really there's no one but you you know
and and eventually you learn it's your
colleagues and the you know it's it's
putting a lot of trust in the people
that are around you
and and realizing more importantly that
they trust you you know or gaining that
trust and so um yeah it's that part was
a big adjustment i just come from
working on giant films
which
are about as hierarchical as it gets you
know um
and uh and also there's uh
there was definitely a lot of learning
around um you know i'm a musician right
and an experimental one you know uh
at that um and so
like i said there's a lot of um
a lot of
my investment as an artist has been in
culturing emotions and
really being able to it's like an acting
you know like i said earlier it's sort
of like you know you really are taking
an emotion amplifying it and overselling
it through your guitar or your piano
playing or whatever it happens to be
um and you know i get to valve and
for valve to function the way it does
everyone has to have a certain level of
object objectivity and sort of
you know making good decisions and
making right not not impulse driven you
know yeah i'm pissed off you know like
those are not the kinds of decisions you
want to be making at a place like that
you want to be objectively thinking
things through and um and so it did take
me a while to
adjust just even my inner personality to
um to not function more on an impulse
level which is kind of more the art side
of things typically speaking and and
find out finding a way to meld those two
things together there is sort of a
hierarchical structure of sorts it's
just not explicit it's implicit and it's
ever-changing you know what i mean um
every project you work on you kind of
figure out where you sit and who you
trust and and also like who on this
project needs
to be given responsibility or given
power right because
you know it's there's always going to be
somebody who's going to lead or that is
going to manage all the the bug triage
or or whatever and as long as you're
watching and paying attention
um you can grant them that power
over you you know and if other people
see you doing that then
as a group you kind of we all sort of
end up agreeing hey we're gonna let this
person you know let is not quite the
right word but we're gonna you know
observe their necessity for having a
certain amount of power right um yeah
and it makes sense
yeah and it's it's i mean it's people
act like it's a really and i know when i
got there i was just like now i remember
having dinner with gabe and going
this is just now come on like
tell me how does this actually work you
know um
the problem is with 300 employees and
there isn't you know i i don't know
exactly the breakdown like how many of
them are
on the production side versus steam
business side versus
legal versus whatever yeah of course
there's only so there's a lot of
opportunity costs to uh taking you know
75 people and trying to get a game made
like there's you know as much as it
seems like valve often isn't
there's just a bunch of people sitting
around
you know sipping gin and tonics by a
pool everybody's working they're working
all the time it's just you don't always
see their it doesn't always end up
coming out or it comes out years later
it gets turned into something else so
uh there's everybody is accounted for i
guess is what i'm saying people are all
doing something so you almost have to
take them you'd have to
it's like a revolution you'd have to
you'd have to stir up a bunch of people
to
leave what they're currently working on
and come work on something else and
there's games or
stuff that gets canceled there's
prototypes canceled is even
too
top-down too too
authoritarian a word i guess sometimes
it stuff just falls apart like it
becomes
clear to people that this just isn't
working out uh or
like
i was just describing something's kind
of going along and maybe it's not going
it's not turning into the thing that
everybody had hoped it would turn into
but it's still a group of people and
you're all sort of working on it
together
and you don't always want to admit that
and then slowly people peel off to
go work on something else that's been
proposed it makes it sound uh
insane and it it makes more sense when
you're there it's not as as chaotic as
as uh i'm probably making it sound but
yeah there's a high quality bar part of
that is because
by the time something reaches
like full production mode there's a lot
of buy-in from people and there are
people working on it because they want
to work on it right
so
yeah there's a lot of enthusiasm usually
it in that middle part and then there's
just despair and
by the end you're just you're
everybody's sad and ready to be done